you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess calm
and I am playing a game against computer
impossible with a 15-5 increment since
the computer doesn't like to think a
little bit more of a cushion not much
okay I guess we're going to try for e5
against c4 all right g3 probably just
Knight to f6 here yeah why not
where else is he going to go actually he
might have another spot to go to yeah I
want to go with c6 I don't think I'm
going to go forward with a a c6 d5 idea
so I'm okay with obstructing my C pawn
and the reason why I'm holding off on my
night because sometimes it could come to
e7
depending on what this night does there
is a some h5h for ideas looks very cave
mannish but it is an idea so I'm going
to drop my push-up on c5 I was planning
on ac45 if Knight c3 I was going to come
immediately out to be four so probably
just d6 here I can't get in d5 there has
too much control over d5 just
questioning the move order some I don't
know that it really matters I'm thinking
about d6 and a6 to preserve my bishop
let's start with d6 you may see Bishop
takes Knight computer does some wacky
things okay probably a six now so I
guess white is preparing well that's a
bit surprising and I think he could play
d4 straight away what is that about
huh okay I haven't seen this usually
it's a 92 and then you have this advance
so I have three attackers on this is
white preparing to meet eat takes D
width in in between Bishop takes Knight
hmm very surprising move I haven't seen
this before okay
well okay if they give it I mean they
could damage the my queen side here he
takes D Bishop takes Knight pawn takes
and then II takes drop my Bishop back I
wouldn't be too upset having a double
isolated C pawns the pawn on c6 would do
a good job in limiting the c3 Knight
I really don't see a reason not to just
capture here if they just recapture I
could take with the night it's important
I take with the night
Bishop takes I lose a piece with capture
and then recapture on d4 well I just
come I guess I'm going to learn a little
something here let's see what the big
trick is yeah okay
Wow
have the bishop pair there's some light
square weaknesses over here clearly I
mean that's a that's a pretty important
Bishop so where to I could consider b4
hmm I mean it's not my first thought my
first thought is to just drop the bishop
back to a7 should there be some pressure
on this guy I have 97 hmm well I think
what white is going to be doing is
putting the night on e too so that a
move like Bishop h3 can be bet with
Knight f4 dislodging my bishop hmm well
my decision at least at this point is
either Bishop b4 or Bishop a7 I don't
want to go here just uh runs into
potentially a pond push with tempo and
also on b6 it gets in the way of my rook
for when it plays to the B file or if it
plays to the B file I'd like to observe
the white pawn directly probably a good
idea to just maintain the bishops not
going in for that capture
let's just drop back o9f three typical
computer so I guess on Bishop h3 there's
going to be Knight g5 Bishop g2 rook g1
and my Bishop is out of squares so so
much for that idea to stop castling I'd
end up in some hot water
I could insert a check but I don't think
that that's an inconvenience Bishop e3
currently this is unprotected where
would I like to go with my knight
97 into
five
it seems so natural though just to go on
f6 if there's ever a pin I could get out
of that with h6
if I play Knight f6 what about Queen e2
I just block am i okay with going on
castled hmm because I couldn't play
Bishop e6 hmm
so Knight f6 Queen e2 Queen e7 the
Queen's are exchanged or quick castles I
could play rook to e8 hmm feels like the
hell I would have a little bit too much
of a lead in development there and I'm
not in time to kind of secure my knight
position and get my rooks connected
let's consider once more Knight f6 Queen
e2 Queen e7 let's say the Queen's are
exchanged king is on e7
kingside castle now it just feels too
uncomfortable with the night coming here
and something with something without I'm
going to go a knight to e7 yeah let's go
in id seven still watching over this guy
and now probably just Castle yeah can't
do without that okay
h6 seems logical for not only a flight
square but also robbing the minor pieces
of g5 and also I could maybe maintain a
bishop on h3 hmm okay let's
at this
okay so possibilities for Knight f5
hitting the bishop I could pin the night
hmm that's not an easy pin to get out of
I should probably start poking around at
these light squares all right holes
right here on h3 and f3 and they don't
have a light square bishop let's start
with Bishop g4 Queen d7 Wow okay I
really have to be so concerned about
this could trade bishops first okay
I'm inviting one other pieces forward
maybe I should let white take me I don't
know if my rook would really be so
inconvenience by being on a seven
instead of a 8mm at the same time maybe
I don't want to allow this square for a
white night so if I take rook takes
maybe I could then play c5 that might
not be a bad idea I help out the rook a
little bit but maybe I could even focus
in on the e5 square and my knight could
look to then observe it these ax observe
the light squares let's let's take
with the idea of c-5 keeping it a bit
closed keeping this square making sure
that a piece can't make use of this
square it's pretty slow move
gotta say I like my position it wouldn't
be the first time I like my one of my
positions against the impossible one
Knight f5 rookie four as otherwise
Knight and d4 is going to win the
exchange
Queen d7 seems like a good start
threatening Knight f5 into here huh all
right let's start with this I'm also
connecting rooks can't be bad
okay so Knight f5 Queen d3 must be the
way out of the pin
a good harmony between my bishop and
structure regarding of the fixed ponds
so one day maybe he could go into pacman
mode and take out these guys
I could just occupy an open file rook F
to e8 not sure it matters which rook
goes to the e-file hmm what about Queen
f5 pretty direct stuff Queen f5 rook
takes Knight Bishop takes Knight Queen
f1 feels like the computer will be able
to defend in yeah then I have to worry
about my c7 pawn I feel like I could
take a slower approach here and still be
better I don't know how much better but
hmm I guess I'm going to go with this
one hmm
now let's go here maybe my king wants to
take a step towards f8 ok I could go for
Queen exchange if I want it maybe I do I
mean would I really have an attack here
I could go in for a night here as a
start and then look to maybe take out
the night and jump in here hmm also
don't have much time yeah I'm going to
hang on to my bishop for just a little a
little bit longer hmm let's see Queen f5
Queens are exchanged and then the knight
recapture hmm yeah I think I'm going to
go for this with the knight recapture I
was just a little bit concerned maybe my
bishops being going to be trapped don't
think that's the case
okay in-game town probably King at f8 or
exchange and then post up here on d4
yeah let's demote that night and then
jump into d4 this is closer to being a
possibility how to win this ending well
I guess we'll start with Bishop here get
the King involved I could get the night
off and then this Knight can't move so
easily I have him under control maybe
this is a moment to exchange Knights
let's do that I know he's not the
greatest piece but Bishop versus Knight
still many pawns on board they just put
a pond on a light square they did it did
um I just want the night to move but he
could always return in defend a - I feel
like the computer can I mean I feel like
a well I'm recalling the computer kind
of making mistakes and endings like this
it's another pawn on a light square Wow
about this move hmm
oh wait a second you got to be kidding
me my fish abstract oh my God my bishop
is trapped
oh wow oh my goodness Wow
my bishop is trapped I got no moves oh
man I guess I have to try for this kind
of stuff now cool
ah man what's the best way to kind of
try for something I guess I have to get
my rook active with my bishops big dummy
oh okay I could get to pass pawns here
may still be interesting
take here take here and then this or
take your first probably take here first
yeah and then take on f5 got to take out
two pawns just just right around the
point I was saying yeah computer usually
messes up Oh white is really faster huh
on take
that's such a cool shot that's so cool
on takes there isn't even the capture
but rather a for pawn takes pawn takes
and I I can't get inside the box I need
to be able to make use of this square
and I can't okay so I can't take the
knight so my only tries to push but I
imagine it's just lost at this stage
well my certain I can't take the night
on takes night a for straightaway hmm on
takes pawn takes can you have six yeah
I'm not there okay let's put some pawns
and just see how it works out in the end
I guess I have to just keep going here
King position first feel like I need a
little bit more King position although
this night is going to take here it's
lost no matter how you look at it I
guess King has to move now and where to
go exactly hmm Knight takes here a king
move what is it doing it's just making
suboptimal moves and toying with me
alrighty
just making it look close that's what
the computer is doing all right got to
push again
well if I
this so I guess I have to
it's either king h3 or just push I guess
we're going to give a check go here so I
get a mate to okay
they're allowing me to clean this was
unnecessary I don't see any perpetual
why would take this kind of approach I
have no idea
it's trolling me computer for M the
impossible troll yeah I don't I don't
see any perpetual Kings going to run
play out a few more I guess
check along
agonal yeah that night as soon as the
king gets close to the night I am in big
trouble like right here the night will
be blocking the next check yeah a good
time to just throw in the towel oh man
that was really just didn't see that
coming my bishop being trapped like that
it's completely unaware of it being
limited um I'm guessing it's a slightly
better ending for me I don't know if
it's something I'd be able to convert
but yeah I mean I I know I must have
been the side better they're giving up
the light square bishop like that hmm
we'll have a look at it with the engine
stock fish but yeah normally it's you
put the night on e to first and then
play d4 so you're not going to see too
many humans to d4 here give up the light
square Bishop Knight f3 97 yeah I would
revisit this same position but clearly
do something different in the ending I
don't think there was a way I could have
exploited the pin
maybe this but I don't know I'll be able
to defend the square from Queen h3 and
Queen g2 and meanwhile what am i doing
about my c7 pawn not cool so yeah this
ending is really the one to have a look
at I think it was okay to do this I mean
okay a bit debatable to give up a strong
night like this mmm
I mean eventually I guess they're
they're going to
force my night off anyhow after Knight
to f3 mmm yeah I'm pulling my bishop
away from controlling these pawns which
ultimately killed me in the game could
have been avoided but I just didn't see
this what the idea was with g4 I only
saw it as oh that's another pawn on the
light square potential target for me
no this Knight was really killing my
bishop it was too late when I realized
this is serious I gotta move my Bishop
here to h7 hikes or do something like g6
oh man the ending it was just toying
with me it's not the the computer did
not show the greatest technique in this
ending I'm pretty sure right around here
yeah I'm pretty sure the knight could
just get back in the ball game like so
or right around this point Knight takes
pawn and then the knight is back to help
defend the pawns defend against the
pawns and super super quick instead of
how they did it with b4 but I guess it
was winning no matter what with the
approach white took but you're not going
to see a human allow me to even promote
so cleaner approach would have been to
just take at this stage after I push to
take on c5 ok well let's have a look at
it with stockfish and see maybe what was
missed okay stockfish let's see oh we
can learn here even ish doesn't like d4
idea not a winning advantage but yeah as
mentioned you're not going to have too
many human players go in for this giving
up the light square bishop to damage the
queenside structure
I'm happy to see that it likes Knight to
e7 let me just consider Knight f6 not
too much of a change on the evaluation
but yeah this kind of Concerned me you
know I'm on castled and pots of Bishop
g5 connected with Knight here concerned
me hmm I guess it was okay I mean I
could have gone for that suggesting h3
here but suppose Bishop g5 mmm Bishop g4
and I could look to undermine d4 still
messy seeing a little fluctuation there
with the evaluation okay I could have
gone with the either one I guess it
seemed more solid avoiding any great
let's say development lead by white so I
Castle Bishop g4 Castle okay
h6 hmm a really big fan of h6 wants to
come straight out with Bishop g4
approaching upon + Queen d3 hmm could I
go
for that I don't know if the Queen would
move though
if I do Bishop g4 suppose Bishop here 90
g6 and wants to play h3 here something's
going wrong for white yeah you know what
if white is here to defend the pond
they're running into some trouble with
you know these ideas piling up on the
knight or actually just straight away
Queen to f6 hmm yeah let me make a dummy
move here
c5 look at that c5 with the idea to now
target the night Queen f6 is a move
Knight e5 is a move ah interesting
coming straight out and pinning the
night instead of h6 not bad but I had my
reasons behind doing that just to avoid
any piece going to a g5 that would have
been interesting though putting
immediate pressure on the night and the
center as a result c5 oh I don't want to
play c5 here what's he ever going to do
he has to get into the ball game like
that I don't know
even now I lose my advantage by
capturing and then playing c5 it's even
I had to play C 5 here
oh I don't know how many of you watching
right now would play c5 in this position
to kill your own Bishop I don't know
about that
that's tough yeah I find it very
difficult to do something like that I I
mean I guess you could do this but mmm
doesn't feel right just to maintain the
bishops and now he's going to have to
work like this it is a position where
you have the time to do that you know
it's not a crazy out of control
position it's so it's one that is under
under control not dynamic right here a
pretty static position I'd say with
these uh fixed pawns in the center so
interesting c5 okay I went with the
trade and f5 didn't come to mind and I
say it's really weakening to e6 went
with something more solid suggesting f5
again trying to take advantage of this
pin to peace Queen d3 f4 interesting
maybe I should um look into this move
more I mean normally what would keep me
away from playing this move is the
weakness that it creates here and
there's already a a pawn around
controlling it however I do have a light
square bishop around that could kick
away a major piece at least from that
Square even take out a knight
interesting idea now that we're not a
winning evaluation but yeah that's
something that came to mind here at 5f4
I was I'm at this stage I'm basically of
the mentality to play within the
structure I don't I wasn't really
feeling a need to change the structure
at all you know
I'm just thinking about occupying the
open file you know five yeah it's just
even so what does it say about this
ending coming up even even even it's not
budging from even its going to budge
soon yeah it doesn't like the night move
but I don't think that that could be a
losing move but yak just kingi seven
straight away and after G for the King
move is losing this will probably be a
growing advantage just with some time
here yup that'll do it
mmm I just missed the idea what more can
I say
yeah I didn't see that my bishop was one
cooked piece well the night really kills
all the squares you know he only has to
save squares and the King's ready to
take away these last two Wow okay let's
just see hmm well there's a change there
okay now it's going back up was there
ever an opportunity farming here night
there's a cool move very clean well it's
a clean move but beyond this Knight move
it wasn't the clean approach but it was
always he was always winning a little
trolling going on by the computer hmm
that's no that's actually something why
is it going with this move as I was
pointing out Knight c5 is the cleanest
in a winning move but hmm this
apparently is not I mean that's that's a
big shift isn't it plus 49 and now it's
just plus one hmm
okay so I could maybe hold this do I
have some perpetual hmm how'd it go with
King h3 first after the pawn push even
even here it's uh I guess a draw I have
some perpetual in the end I imagine
we're still both going to Queen Wow
weird play by the computer allowing me
to get back in the game I didn't take
advantage of it King h3 apparently and
now I'm threatening this and then
pushing twice Oh King here now f4 knight
takes detail
xD 6f3 to race check in each to promote
and I guess I have a perpetual here I
don't know that's it's going to be
difficult to find a perpetual here yeah
with the king he could kind of run
around here yeah I'd be hard-pressed to
find a perpetual but yeah interesting to
see these these moves by white allowing
me to get back in the game it's reading
as zeros now and not h3 what is it hmm
what is with this first King h3 move hmm
King eh 3 instead of pawn push that's
what I did in the game I push the pond
then I went g2 King h3 and then this so
I mean it's a position here where we
both have Queens and I'm on move and
compare this I guess with the suggested
king h3 C takes d6g to Kim Ji Won f3
they push I'm getting mate oh that's
interesting
okay so f3 night C v f2 king h2
oh my goodness it's a draw because I'm
cleaning first and I'm still not able to
win this position oh wow that's that's
instructive right there going with the
king before the pond I didn't I didn't
even consider I mean I didn't work that
one out and even the slightest Wow
I'm just gonna have to trust that yeah
this is a this is a draw but I'd
actually see myself losing this I think
more often than winning this somehow
yeah my king is going to be out of play
I'm going to have to be much more
accurate with with the checks I'm giving
oh wow so King h3 right here and I'm
actually queening before white hmm
because I played f3 and the check that
allowed the king to step up King h3
first however king h3 captures push kim
ji-won f3 and now has to do Knight c5
stuff Knight see
five okay this would stop me from coming
over it's a bit complicated I must say
yeah I definitely wasn't able to I don't
know if I would have been able to work
that one out with the time constraint
whether to go with the king first or the
pawn first but kind of oddball play by
the computer in the endgame and yeah I
just overlooked that move which really
killed my bishop and from there a good
point to resign any check this night is
a super defender against Queen checks
yikes
just as I was saying I get good
positions against computer and then
there you have it a king e7 move throws
it all away
okay well still I hope you're able to
maybe take something away from this game
as usual feel free to leave any feedback
in the comment section below and I hope
you got something out of it that's all
for now take care bye
you